hey draco being in a
4x6 cell 24 hours a day right
that's got to be mentally [ __ ] with
you man oh yeah crazy
like do you kind of go crazy that you
like i feel like it's kind of hard to be
the same when you come out from that
yeah
all you got is your thoughts that's all
you got
okay how'd you get through that man uh
i need to stay on the phone all [ __ ]
days see not down there
oh yeah you know no phone [ __ ] are you
talking about
that's true when you wasn't in there you
were uh all day every time i called it
on the phone
but uh just like reading books and
working out and listening to the radio i
guess
because it ain't really too much else to
do that's crazy
listen to other people talk all day long
about
[ __ ] you just hear people screaming from
their cell y'all tell us to yeah
that's crazy yeah i can't even imagine
man that's got to be like
i feel like like i don't know how that
really rehabilitates anybody you know
what i'm saying
crazy like that gotta make anybody like
i don't care who you are you can't come
out
from that and and be the same yeah like
bro
they know what they doing that's why so
many smokers to go to 10-day flashes
i've seen they come five times my whole
time my the whole time i was in the
county i've seen them come five times
i'm like boss get these [ __ ] type of
[ __ ] like 10-day flashes and
and violations but they always want to
hear the [ __ ] this is my first case
they tried to do me like i was john
gotti
oh my god damn that is crazy
like my whole time this is my first life
right first time yeah
god damn uh you you mentioned reading uh
draco what books did you uh
kind of like that kind of helped get you
through uh at that time
all right um i
think napoleon hill
ought to read y'all mine the parliament
here i win the dead when
he said jail books those are the ones
that's in there [ __ ] that's trying to
rehabilitate
get their thoughts right in these
sharpies right yeah jail books
then you got the irvings and [ __ ] you
know everybody out there
well you said what is it urban it's like
an urban novel yeah like like a
like basically a book that kind of
that's like written like a movie to wear
like some hood [ __ ] like a hood movie
like
yeah i can't read that it's like a hood
wing i was reading them about it no
sister soldiers and all the little shits